Kim Kardashian standing by her big  snapchat decision m'kay shocked us all  Sunday night when she released edited  clips of her husband Kanye West's  conversation with Taylor Swift about his  song famous a convo from months ago Ann  Taylor responded  claiming Kanye never asked her about the  lyric in which he calls her a [ __ ] I  made that [ __ ] famous quote Kim doesn't  care she doesn't regret it this was  something that was not Kanye wanting to  do this this was Kim wanting to do this  for her husband our source says Kim has  been upset with Taylor since her Grammys  acceptance speech there are going to be  people along the way who will try to  undercut your success or take credit for  your accomplishments or your fame she  gets up on that stage and essentially  dedicates her entire speech - slamming  Kanye  that's exactly why Kim released it our  source also says Kanye tried to reach  out to Taylor in February but the two  never spoke  you